[موسيقى]
قبل 13 عاما عاشت هايتي زلزالا مدمرا
تجاوز سبع درجات على سلم ريختر وعوده
بحياه نحو 200 الف شخص وشرد نحو مليونين
وبعد تسعه ايام اعلنت الحكومه الهيتيه
انتهاء مرحله البحث والانقاذ مع تضاؤل فرص
العثور على المزيد من الاشخاص على قيد
الحياه قله من الاشخاص المحاصرين يمكنهم
البقاء على قيد الحياه لمده طويله خلال
الزلازل واول اثنتين وسبعين ساعه تعد حرجه
لانها توفر اعلى فرص لوجودنا جيم لكن
يتعين على اجهزه التنسيق في البلد المتضرر
اتخاذ القرار الصعب بشان متى تتوقف عن
البحث عن الاشخاص المحاصرين المتبقين تحت
الانقاض متوسط الوقت لذلك عاده ما يرابح
بين خمسه ايام وسبعه ويعتمد على عوامل مثل
الطقس والهزات الارتداديه ومدى سرعه وصول
فرق الانقاذ والمعدات لكن لخبراء في
الزلازل تشير الى ان الافراد يظلون على
قيد الحياه لمده تصل الى 13 يوما اذا كان
لديهم امكانيه الوصول الى الماء واكثر من
ذلك اذا ما وفر لهم الطعام العامل الاكثر
الحاحا هو الحصول على الرعايه الطبيه
للاشخاص تحت المباني المنهره قبل انهيار
اجسادهم او نسفهم وفضل لحاله الطقس
الحاليه يعد انخفاض درجه حراره الجسم امرا
ممكنا وربما يموت الناس للاسف بسبب ذلك
وبدون ماء قد يفقد الكثير منهم حياتهم
تلتزم بعض فرق الانقاذ الدوليه ما يعرف
بقاعده الاربعه وتفترض بقاء المحاصرين تحت
الانقاض على قيد الحياه لمده اربع دقائق
دون هواء واربعه ايام دون ماء واربعه
اسابيع دون طعام وتتحدث عن 48 ساعه ذهبيه
يبقى القول ان وقف عمليه الانقاذ قرار صعب
الا انه بالمقابل يسمح بتركيز الموارد على
رعايه الالاف من الناجين الاخرين وعمليه
التعافي والمساعده في ازاله الانقاض لهذا
ووفق بروتوكولات دوليه معتمده يجب ان يكون
عمال الانقاذ سريعين لتقييم الاماكن التي
من المرجح ان يجدوا فيها ناجين داخل
المباني المنهاره ويمكن الاستفاده من
كاميرات الفيديو عبر الفجوات الموجوده في
الانقاض ومعدات التصوير الحراري لتحديد
اماكن الناجين ويمكن لمعدات الصوت
المتخصصه اكتشاف اضعف الاصوات في نطاق
امتار قليله وتعد الكلاب المدربه فعاله
للغايه باستخدام حاسه الشم في كشف ناجين
نهيك بتعاون المجتمعات المحليه في تحديد
الاماكن ويمكن ايضا استخدام اجهزه الكشف
عن ثاني اكسيد الكربون للعثور على الناجين
الذين فقدوا الوعي حيث يكتشف المنقذون
تركيزه في الهواء عند نفته ممن مازالوا
يتنفسون